a big part of language learning to me is
that it'd be natural I acquire so many
words through listening and reading I
can't possibly use them all right away
there's no opportunity to use them
there's a gradual process where words
that we have seen and we're starting to
become familiar with eventually become
passive vocabulary and eventually become
active vocabulary I don't think you can
Short Circuit the process by trying to
use them right away and if you do you'll
only slow down your acquisition of a
richer and richer passive vocabulary
which is a base that you need for
comprehension and it's the base upon
which all other language skills are
built so no don't try to use it right
away